mesdames et messieurs bonjour je vais
être bref et synthétique pour vous dire
qu'à partir de lundi 16 mai le port du
masque ne sera plus obligatoire dans
l'ensemble des transports en commun dans
notre pays plus obligatoire mais
recommandée pourquoi d'abord cela fait
cela s'inscrit dans la stratégie globale
de réduction progressive des mesures de
freinage en cours dans notre pays parce
que comme l'a dit gabriela talent la
situation épidémique s'améliore nous ne
sommes pas encore sortis de cette
cinquième vague la part de me n'est pas
terminé mais le nombre de nouveaux
diagnostics au quotidien diminue la
situation hospitalière s'améliore et
donc il nous considérons qu'il n'est
plus adaptée de maintenir cette
obligation de port du masque et dans les
transports en commun donc à partir de
lundi 16 mai ça ferait un peu de
respiration de temps que les
températures sont en train d'augmenter
dans notre pays par ailleurs nous
suivons cela une recommandation de le
cdc l'organisme européen de lutte contre
les maladies transmissibles qui vient de
publier ce matin cette recommandation
qui va dans le sens de ce que nous
étions nous mêmes en train de décider
dans le cadre du conseil de défense et
de sécurité nationale réunis sous
l'égide du président de la république en
revanche nous maintenons les autres
mesures de gestion qui sont en vigueur
je pense aux hôpitaux aux ehpad le past
and i terre restera en vigueur au moins
jusqu'à cet été de la même manière le
port du masque qui restera obligatoire
parce que dans les hôpitaux il ya trop
de personnes qui sont fragiles le virus
circule encore ne voulons pas faire
prendre de risques aux personnes malades
ou très âgés